[Música]
buenos días y muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros en france 24 para esta
entrevista en exclusiva con el
presidente del supremo tribunal
electoral de brasil luis roberto barroso
buenos días y muchas gracias señor
barroso por conceder esta entrevista a
nuestro canal buenos días es un placer
conversar con
usted preside el supremo tribunal
electoral y es también uno de los once
miembros de la corte suprema desde el
inicio de la pandemia vimos muchos
ataques contra las instituciones
democráticas incluso este tribunal por
parte del presidente jair bolsonaro y de
sus seguidores la democracia en brasil
está en peligro y creo que la democracia
en todo el mundo vive un momento
relativamente delicado
[Música]
y algunos autores llaman recesión
democrática y
retroceso democrático
constitucionalismo abusivo o legalismo
autocrático en un proceso es un proceso
que ocurre en diferentes partes del
mundo en
países como hungría polonia turquía
georgia y
en venezuela nicaragua el salvador el
salvador- son países en que además son
países en los que la democracia ha sido
colocada en jaque o ha sucumbido con
virtud
en mi visión hay tres fenómenos
distintos que ocurren en el mundo
el populismo el extremismo y el
autoritarismo años
son distintos pero se han juntado para
producir paz para este cuadro de erosión
de la democracia la democracia
es un fenómeno mundial que se ha
manifestado en democracias estables y
democracia estadounidense y la británica
y creo que también tuvo repercusiones en
brasil de
la diferencia entre los países entre los
que consiguen resistir a esta ola
y los que no consiguen resistir
ahora sí yo creo que esta ola llegó a
brasil pero las instituciones lograron
establecer límites al ejercicio abusivo
del poder
no sin costes y no sin desgastes
creo que conseguimos superar la peor
fase y creo que tendremos elecciones
libres limpias y democráticas el próximo
año aunque bastante polarizadas y
bastante polarizados este año presidente
hierva al sonar este año bolsonaro está
con las urnas electrónicas y lanzó una
campaña a favor del voto impreso el
asunto llegó a ser votado en el congreso
y bolsonaro perdió usted como presidente
del tribunal superior electoral siempre
defendió que las urnas electrónicas son
seguras el asunto realmente está
encerrado o es de esperar que el año que
viene vuelva a salir a colación
especialmente en caso de un resultado
desfavorable para el actual presidente
en la vida a veces hay difuntos que son
difíciles de ser enterrados más me gusta
tener la expectativa de que este ha sido
definitivamente sepultado
desde 1996 brasil adoptó un sistema de
urna son estrictamente electrónicas y
electrónico
que fue decisivo dicho sea para nosotros
para acabar con los fraudes electorales
que ocurrían en la época del voto con
papeletas y no antes y desde 1996 hasta
hoy nunca fue documentado en algún
episodio de fraude en el sistema
electrónico de votación
por lo tanto tenemos mucha confianza en
este sistema y
él posee diversos mecanismos de
auditoría para impedir cualquier tipo de
manipulación humana razón humana
es importante destacar que las urnas
electrónicas brasileñas nunca están
conectadas entre sí por consecuencia no
son susceptibles de ataques remotos no
pueden ser hackeadas de modo que los
ataques
de bolsonaro contra las armas
electrónicas no estaban basados en
hechos reales sus nuevas muchos
sospechaban que fuese una justificación
para una eventual derrota proporcionado
en las urnas de 2022 para una acusación
falsa de fraude ya había muchos que
sospechaban que había un esquema de
fraude por detrás del intento
revolucionario de volver al voto impreso
con recuento público y manual yo no
preciso emitir un juicio sobre las
intenciones de los otros para mí basta
tener la evaluación de que el sistema
electrónico es seguro benefició a brasil
y nosotros impedimos su cambio en
realidad nosotros trabajamos para
impedir este cambio quien quien decidió
fue el congreso nacional no me llega
polémica sobre hubo témpore en el medio
de la polémica sobre el voto impreso y
jair bolsonaro lanzó ataques personales
contra usted
incluso le acusó de defender la
pedofilia qué opina de este
comportamiento inédito en la historia
reciente de brasilia
yo no me siento ofendido pero
evidentemente el hecho de tener un
presidente que se comporta con falta de
compostura es negativo para el país
para mí no hace mucha diferencia porque
yo vivo con integridad y con educación
pero evidentemente da lástima que un
líder político de un país se comporte de
forma grosera y poco elegante
la peor cosa que yo podría haber hecho
sería responder a la grosería ya la
falta de decoro y comportándome de la
misma forma hay un pasaje bonito de un
libro del filósofo nietzsche en que dice
que tenemos que combatir a los monstruos
sin convertirnos en monstruos yo mantuve
la compostura todo el tiempo pero
respondí inmediatamente a todas las
acusaciones que envolvían la integridad
del sistema de voto con la firmeza que
considere necesarias algunas personas me
preguntan no cree que bolsonaro merece
punición de la forma que yo consigo la
vida para ciertas personas el peor
castigo es ser quienes son en octubre
supremo en octubre el tribunal superior
electoral decidió por unanimidad no
declarar ilegítimo el mandato de
bolsonaro y de su vice por el uso masivo
de fic news durante la campaña de 2018
pero hubo una advertencia si eso se
repite en 2022 los responsables irán a
la cárcel mientras tanto bolsonaro ya ha
migrado al telegram una aplicación rusa
que no limita la difusión masiva de
contenidos teniendo en cuenta que el
mandatario se está preparando para
repetir la misma estrategia de noticias
falsas que osó en 2018 usted sigue
pensando que esta decisión fue la mejor
la cuestión de no declarar el mandato
legítimo tuvo que ver con la falta de
pruebas suficientes y adecuadas
la verdad es que en 2018 el país el
tribunal electoral un país
y a lo mejor el mundo no estaban
totalmente preparados para enfrentar
este nuevo fenómeno
es la utilización de las redes sociales
en campañas electorales orales
tradicionalmente en brasil tenía más
tiempo de anuncios en televisión y radio
era el candidato favorito güero era el
que tenía una ventaja competitiva sobre
los otros temas un nuevo fenómeno
irrumpió en las elecciones brasileñas en
cilleros y fue a la pérdida de
importancia de la televisión y la
ascensión de las redes sociales pero en
las elecciones locales de 2020 cuando yo
ya presidía este tribunal nosotros ya
nos habíamos preparado para esto por lo
tanto establecimos alianzas con todas
las plataformas tecnológicas para
revertir los comportamientos coordinados
no auténticos y para la reducción de
contenidos que atacaban la justicia
electoral la integridad del sistema
electoral de la democracia creo que es
posible modera creo que es posible
moderar en gran parte los contenidos en
las redes sociales pero nadie debe
cultivar la ilusión de que se pueden
impedir completamente circulen mentiras
y acusaciones falsas de unos contra
otros
la corte suprema tuvo un papel crucial
para impedir que el ex presidente luiz
inácio lula da silva participas en las
elecciones de 2018 y usted votó a favor
de la inelegibilidad de lula pero en
2022 célula podrá ser de nuevo candidato
porque algunas condenas fueron anuladas
incluso lula es el favorito de las
encuestas para el año que viene visto
desde fuera parece un poco
contradictorio usted cree contradictorio
el señor novais
mire la corte suprema no juzgo el mérito
de las condenas del expresidente lula
yo mismo desconozco el mérito de estos
procesos judiciales y él había sido
condenado en primera instancia a
condenar después fue condenado por un
tribunal de apelación de segunda
instancia y la condena fue mantenida por
el tribunal superior de justicia
supremo no este asunto nunca había
llegado a la corte suprema carlos por
esta razón la corte suprema no tiene una
posición sobre el mérito de los casos
sobre la inocencia o la culpabilidad
en el caso de las elecciones de 2018 en
el período del registro de las
candidaturas el expresidente lula estaba
condenado y en base a la legislación
fue aplicada a alguien condenado por un
tribunal de apelación de segunda
instancia no no puede participar en las
elecciones supremo
por lo tanto fue aplicada a la
legislación vigente cuando una cuestión
técnico procesal llegó a la corte
suprema el supremo por mayoría de liberó
el juez que le había condenado en
primera instancia no tenía competencia
por una cuestión técnica y anuló este
juicio al no existir más este juicio el
expresidente lula puede ser candidato
como cualquier otra persona oa quien no
tenga una condena en vigor tanto que no
veo una contradicción en la posición del
supremo
evidentemente hubo un vaivenes en la
posición general de la justicia volcando
fatah es contra volviendo a los ataques
contra la democracia el 7 de septiembre
hubo en brásil manifestaciones contra
los principales poderes del estado
especialmente contra la corte suprema
los manifestantes pidieron incluso la
vuelta a la dictadura y un 'estado de
sitio' después se repentinamente
bolsonaro dio marcha atrás y cambio de
estrategias que aconteció en su opinión
hay una explicación bastante clara
realmente hubo convocatorias para
manifestaciones el 7 de septiembre que
es el día nacional de brasil el día de
la independencia de brasil
el propio presidente en sus seguidores
en todo brasil convocaron a
manifestaciones que estarían
concentradas en brasilia y en sao paulo
muchas de estas concentraciones pedían
el cierre del congreso y de la corte
suprema y la vuelta del régimen militar
en algunas defendían que los jueces del
supremo fuesen retirados a la fuerza
y una serie de otras barbaridades
autoritarias
la expectativa era reunir a más de un
millón de personas en brasilia y otro
millón en san pablo
la verdad es que las manifestaciones
tuvieron un poco más de 100.000 personas
y por lo tanto estas manifestaciones
revelaron el tamaño en mi opinión
diminuto de los extremistas de la
derecha en brasil
y la falta de apoyo para soluciones
consigues
que no estén dentro del marco de las
reglas del juego democrático y un
fracaso
el fracaso del 7 de septiembre fue el
entierro del golpismo en brasil
creo que el reposicionamiento del propio
presidente fue la constatación de que
sus únicas chances están dentro del
juego democrático
situado sin uso democrático muchas
gracias en el barroso por esa entrevista
en exclusiva y gracias a ustedes por
acompañarnos hasta aquí les invitamos a
que sigan nuestra programación en france
24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]